my name is mark rendall
i am a.net developer
but i've been working in this business
for 30 years and over that time i've
worked with some truly horrific
programming languages i'm going to show
you a couple of them
and
uh yeah
so this is not a talk where i'm going to
like audit and review all the
programming languages in the world and
then go ha this one is the worst because
that's just mean
and also it's easy and we all know which
one it is
um
no what we're going to do is we are
going to take
the worst features
from a bunch of programming languages
that might in other ways be very very
good and perfectly acceptable and we're
going to mash them all together and make
the worst programming language that
there has ever been
in
the whole of history
and speaking of history
there is a saying that those who do not
learn from history are unable to iterate
on it and make it worse
and so we should look back
at the history of programming languages
at some truly egregious
terrible examples
like for example
cobol
cobol was the first programming language
that was designed by committee
and it shows
and it shows that the committee there
was no you know when people go there are
no bad ideas
i think that's what happened when they
designed cobalt there are no bad ideas
and so every idea that anybody suggested
they just went yes we'll put that in so
this is hello world in cobalt uh you
identify the division and the program
and then you say this is the
you got the procedure division and then
you just say display hello world and
then you stop run
not sure what happens if you don't stop
run the program just keeps going forever
and
so cobol had a lot of boilerplate and
actually the idea i think behind cobol
was that business people
would be able to write their own
applications that was the dream in the
1960s and we all know how well that's
worked out
business people can't even describe the
applications they want much less write
them
but ibm thought cobalt didn't have
enough boilerplate and so they made
their own version of cobol
and this
i swear to god this is hello world in
ibm cobalt
um
i'm not even gonna try and dig into how
this works because i i can't even
imagine it
um but knowing how much ibm programmers
get paid by the hour
that's about seven and a half thousand
dollars worth of code there
just to print hello world
then there was apl um apl was invented
by kenneth iverson uh as a teaching
language to use in his computer science
and programming classes um it stands for
a programming language because
kenneth wasn't the most creative person
in the world uh outside of his
programming language which actually in a
lot of ways was fantastic so this is
hello world in apl if you just give it a
string it goes well i'll just write that
back out to the standard output and
we're done which is completely sane
this is conway's game of life in apl
that one line of code is the whole of
conway's game of life
now you might notice
some interesting things in that line of
code
like
some of those characters are greek
uh some of them are mathematical
uh some of them i think are just from a
fever dream that kenneth had after
taking some acid with timothy leary in
san francisco
in order to write code in apl you
actually had to buy an apl keyboard
which had all those weird little
squiggles on it and i that that's
brilliant that's um i'm going to invent
a programming language i'm going to say
this is what you need to learn to pass
my course and here's the keyboard it
costs 800
brilliant
then in the 1970s somebody invented a
programming language
called the compiler with no
pronounceable acronym or intercal
and intercal was the first
or it's the first known example of a
joke programming language so this was a
parody of the programming languages that
were around at the time like fortran and
fourth and things like that
and
it was designed to be ridiculously
difficult to code in
um and just also to poke fun at other
programming languages so you notice
four of the lines here start with please
you had to say please on some of the
lines of code when you were writing into
cal if you didn't say please often
enough you would get a compiler error
that said programmer is insufficiently
com
polite
if you just tried to cheat and went well
i just put please at the start of every
line you would get a compiler error that
said programmer is excessively polite
and the correct ratio of pleas to to not
please was not documented anywhere
into cal also did not have the go-to
keyword
it had come from
and so if you wanted to do a conditional
bit and jump to somewhere else in your
program
uh you would have a line that said um
if something and then the next line
would say please do nothing and then
somewhere else in your code you would
have a come from statement that took
control from that please do nothing line
and did something else instead
and
semantically that's identical to go to
it's just done the other way around
intercal was also the worst compiler
ever
so at the time uh
they they benchmarked it and it was
designed to be as slow as if you didn't
have please give up at the end by the
way it would um run your cpu up to 100
usage and just stay there until you turn
the machine off
um they benchmarked into cal uh at the
time to make sure it was as slow as it
could possibly be um and they compared
it to uh i think it was a fortran
application running the
eris
civ of eritosthenes which is the prime
number finder
and the fortran version took half a
second to find all the primes up to one
million and the intercal version took 17
hours
the final results of the benchmark
aren't actually in yet because the jvm
version is still spinning up the virtual
machine
yay java
um
visual basic another joke programming
language that then accidentally got
bought by microsoft and promulgated out
to the world and and people used it to
build things
um in the 90s when uh windows 3.1 and
then windows 95 came along i'd been
working on unix systems and my company
went oh we've got to switch to windows
go and evaluate which are the best um
platforms for for writing windows
applications and it probably would have
been visual basic but i just didn't like
it
um it didn't do object oriented code at
the time and its data access layer was
basically non-existent in visual basic
three they only added that in visual
basic four with the
ado framework and so i went with another
language
gupta sql windows
is there a gupta sql windows user in the
room
no no you're lucky bastards
so this is the gupta sql windows code
editor
and
yes that is a tree view
and yes that is the editor you would
edit so it's like significant white
space but it's not it's actually a tree
view and so you could insert a nested
or insert at same level
and this when you saved your code it
wasn't text it saved your source code as
a binary file
and then the compiler compiled it into
bytecode and then put it in a an
executable with a header and it was just
it wasn't good
and so i i left that behind and moved
onto net
so we are going to
see if we can make something worse than
all of these languages except possibly
into cal but let's see if we can get as
bad as into cal
so we need a name for our language and
nice short names that are easily
googleable
are a key thing when you're creating a
programming language so i'm going to
call it bs
because be able to google that and
there'll be no confusion
people will find that and also
programming languages these days you
need taglines and marketing for it and
all this sort of stuff and so bs's
tagline is going to be why because [ __ ]
you that's why
you can beat that on the recording
so we need our design principles for our
language our bs design principles now a
lot of languages try to create the pit
of success they try to make it easy for
the programmer to do the right thing
that doesn't sound like any fun at all
we want to create the pit of fail
actually that's that's not even that's
not enough i want to create the
booby-trapped aztec temple of fail in my
programming language that's what it
should be like coding in bs you should
feel like harrison ford running away
from a giant boulder and then bumping
into a bunch of
people pointing arrows at you with a
nazi archaeologist
we are not going to trust the programmer
to get simple things right we're going
to make that as difficult as we can
because
programmers know who trusts programmers
to do anything
we're useless we're distracted easily
we're spending half our time on twitter
half our time on something else half our
time playing browser games and we can't
even do fractions properly it's
ridiculous so we're not going to trust
the programmer to get simple things
right but we are going to leave it all
all the really complicated stuff up to
the programmer to deal with and make
sure that they're having to really work
to get this going
and
we should target as many things as
possible so some programming languages
if you look at like rust so rust
specifically targets systems level
programming and then people try and use
it for other things like building
websites and the rust team are like why
are you doing there's there are other
things
use node do something else but no
we if we just focus on doing one thing
well then then we might accidentally do
that and so we're going to try and do
everything so we're going to try and low
level systems and embedded code and rich
graphical user interfaces and websites
and a
something on bs type web framework and
the internet of things and furbies and
vr and ar and metaverse and everything
else
so
we're going to start
we're going to
take sort of one of the
existing programming languages we'll use
that as our base because every
programming language since essentially
the first one has been based on one that
came before it so uh c was based on b b
was based on a a was based on algol
algol was based on fortran it all goes
back that way and so if we move that
forward and go okay that's languages
that were inspired by c
and so we get
php
php is a recursive acronym it originally
stood for um
[Music]
perl hypertext preprocessor i've noticed
it stood for personal home page because
the dude made it to write his personal
home page and then it stood for
um personal hypertext processor but now
it's actually one of those recursive
acronyms it stands for php hates
programmers
because that's the only explanation i
can think of for
php
um so what we're going to take from php
is the total inconsistency php has
shouty case and camelcase and snake case
and pascal case and just all the
different cases all the different ways
of expressing things we're going to have
pointless variable prefixing php all the
variables have to start with a dollar
if everything has to start with a dollar
why does anything have to start with the
dollar
we're going to have the hassle of c and
c plus plus but the performance of
altair basic
which you know if you're not old it
wasn't good
so
we're going to start here's our starter
bs program we have a class because we're
an object-oriented language and we have
a public function underscore underscore
construct because that's how php does
its constructors
we're not going to prefix our variables
with the dollar symbol because we're
european even post brexit i still
consider myself a european so we're
going to prefix our variables with the
euro symbol
and that has the extra advantage the
it's actually quite difficult to type on
most keyboards and so that will make
programmers work for it we're going to
use the minus greater than um symbol for
dereferencing properties and fields and
members inside classes
because dot that's just far too easy who
wants to type one character when you can
be forced to type two
um and we're going to have curly brace
let's start with curly braces and
semicolons we'll think about whether we
want to keep those um and for string
concatenation we're going to use commas
rather than the plus symbol because
yeah because we are
so yes here are here are our key
differences we have an underscore
underscore construct we have the uh
minus arrow
dereferencing and we have commas for
string concatenation and we have our oh
and we have the colon colon for static
methods as well
so that's a good start what else can we
look at uh let's look at python
so
any python programmers in the room
it's it's python
you know it's the most popular
programming language in the world now
and there is a reason for that python is
is actually generally uh very good and
and very reasonable apart from this one
thing this is some broken python code uh
this chucks an error that says invalid
constant when you try to run it
here's the fixed version of that same
code
um
what was wrong with the code on the left
it had a mixture of tabs and spaces for
the indentation
which
i don't know why that happened i opened
it up in my editor and i added some code
and i yeah somehow it it
a tab found its way in there so from
python we're going to take significant
white space and to be fair that we're
not just picking on python here there
are other significant white space
languages like f sharp and haskell and
ocam and
probably others coffeescript whatever
happened to coffeescript i used to like
coffeescript despite the significant
white space
so we're going to use significant
whitespace in bs so this is simplified
bs quite a lot here
we've got our class greeter there and
and our public function construct and
we're going to use two spaces for
indentation
but if you are indenting by four spaces
then you use a tab if you're indenting
by six spaces then you use a tab and two
spaces and if you're indenting by and so
on and so on and so on
so
let's talk about how we're going to do
comments then
because comments you can have line
comments you can have block comments you
can have all sorts of comments and you
need comments in code so that people
know what's going on and why you've made
the decisions
and so in bs
because you're either using a tab and
two space or two spaces or some
combination of those
and so in bs any line that starts
with
a number of spaces that modulo two is
one will be treated as a comment
so if you start a line with a tab and a
single space or a tab in three spaces or
just with seven spaces then everything
after that is a comment
so there you go this is a comment
but you also need so c uh c and c plus
have the slash star and star slash to
start and begin a comment and so if you
use tab space and then space tab on a
blank line then it comments out
everything in between those two things
so that public function foo at the
bottom there is actually commented out
if you use the approved bs editor to
edit your bs code
three thousand pounds a year from my
company then that will gray out ever so
slightly so you'll know that it's been
commented out
the next thing we're obviously going to
have to bring in is common to all
programming languages and it is of
course
null
every language
um
forgotten the guys was it alan kaye
working on the small talk project and he
called um he called null his billion
dollar mistake and i think that's
probably an underestimate i think we're
probably up somewhere around a trillion
by now
every language ever has a null and a
nothing and an undefined and a data and
an empty and a nil and
uh you know javascript's got like eight
different things that all mean null
so so obviously we're going to have that
uh which means we're going to have to do
checking for nulls around the place
and
um there's one language where when
you're checking something and
potentially throwing exceptions it does
it ever so slightly differently to every
other language and that language is ruby
because ruby
in its
every piece of code should look like
you've written a sentence and it should
be readable and it should make
programmers happy and so for some reason
matt's decided that that involved
putting in an unless keyword which was
an alternative to the if keyword so
instead of saying if allowed formats
does not include format raise invalid
format you say raise invalid format
unless
so you raise an exception unless
everything's okay
which is like me running in here and
going everybody get out unless there's
not a fire
it's it's the wrong way round it's i why
why would you do this i don't understand
it so i'm putting it in my language it's
brilliant it we're not going to have if
at all so ruby does have if
bs is not going to have if we're just
going to have unless
also
we're going to have a single exception
and then we'll leave it up to the
programmer to analyze the stack trace
and core dump
to work out what it was that actually
went wrong that exception is going to be
called halt and catch fire and that is a
key word and that just throws an
exception uh it's basically like panic
but much more dramatic
so we're going to say halton catch fire
and then
indentation on the line after you
obviously have to come out you're out
denting after your halt and catch fire
and say unless name does not equal null
um
and so the s now we have exceptions and
exception handling
our next feature
uh does not come from a programming
language at all it comes from an actual
language
is there anybody in from greece
or who knows greek or speaks greek
so this
is a greek
question mark
not a semicolon it's a question mark
that's a greek semicolon
um literally unicode because the greek
question mark looks so much like a
semicolon the unicode just automatically
maps the greek question mark code to
whatever the semicolon is from the same
character set and so in bs your unless
statements
have to end with the greek question mark
not a semicolon degree question mark and
we'll sell keyboards with a special key
that has a greek question mark key on it
and we'll put it right next to the
semicolon key and you'll just have to
remember which one of them is which
so the next language we're going to take
stuff from is javascript and let's be
honest there's a ton of stuff we could
take from javascript the whole
prototypal class based system and
and just
only having floating point numbers that
would be a good one but what we're going
to take from javascript
is
this
so in javascript
blank string does not equal
the string 0
but 0 does equal the blank string and
zero does equal the string zero so yeah
figure that one out false equals
undefined false doesn't equal undefined
and false doesn't equal null but null
does equal undefined and that comes back
as true javascript has type coercion
um
and
if you use double equals or bang equals
to do a comparison then javascript will
do its level best to make what you're
doing true
and it's just because it's like well
programmers want things to be true we
are seekers after truth i should make as
many things true as possible i should
jump through hoops to make things true
so we're going to have this as well but
we're going to take it up a notch and
we're going to say that
zero equals the empty string and zero
equals the zero as a string and also
zero equals the word zero in a string
and 22 divided by seven equals the emoji
for
pi um
so javascript uh
because people kind of went
this is not helping me i need to
actually know whether two things are the
same or not please please please can we
turn this off
but the problem with javascript is you
can't fix it because there's tens of
billions of lines of code of it out
there in web pages and some of it hasn't
been updated since 1996
and so you can't fix javascript and so
they went all right we'll add so if you
use equals equals equals then it'll do
strict equality and so none of these
things then you'll get this through
properly and so we're going to do a
strict equality check as well if you
don't want type coercion but rather than
saying uh equals equals equals we're
just going to like make the
the the equals operator important by
putting an exclamation mark after it
so bang equals bang
means strict does not equal i call that
the shopping trolley operator
so if you want to do a strict equality
check
you have to negate the strict inequality
operator so the strict equality operator
is bang bang equals bang which i call
the person on the hoverboard pushing a
shopping trolley
operator
okay let's talk about strings
so
uh strings we've got multiple formats
for strings we've got ascii and ansi and
and uh unicode and unicode split up into
utf-8 and utf-16 and utf-32 nobody uses
utf-32 anymore windows uses utf-16
internally for everything but the web
uses utf-8
most programming languages these days
say utf-8 so goes strings and python
strings i think now are utf-8 and so we
deal with utf-8 unless we've actually
loaded a library to do something
differently but i want to be able to
cope with all kinds of strings so if you
have a string literal that's enco
enclosed in single quotes that's an
ascii string if you enclose it in pairs
of single quotes that's an ansi string
if you enclose it in double quotes then
it's a dbcs string if you enclose it in
pairs of double quotes then it's an
ebcdic string that's important because
we want to be able to run bs on ibm
mainframes
because we're going to replace cobol
with bs because those are the only
people in the world who are going to
look at this language and go yeah that's
better
if you enclose your string in what i as
an english person think of as french
quotes then it is a utf-256
encoded string so utf-256 uses 256 bits
for ev it's a 256-bit number for every
character in the alphabet and this is
brilliant because unicode um utf-8 uses
this variable length encoding ut some of
them are sort of one byte and some of
them are four bytes um we're just going
to go to hell with that we're going to
use 16 bytes for every is it 16 or 32 i
can't do math um whatever it is
we're going to use 256 but we will never
run out of address space for characters
no matter because that actually allows
us to have a character for every
subatomic particle in the solar system
that's a lot of characters and i'm going
to make a website where you can upload
any bloody picture you like and i'll
give you back the utf-256 encoding for
it and then you can use it in a string
and then all the programs in the world
will have to come to my web server to
download the character for that youtube
256 thing
[Music]
if you enclose your string in pairs of
french quotes then it's utf-256 but with
string interpolation string
interpolation is not possible with any
of the other string types
because
q
visual basic six in this instance but
you know
um
this was there were lots of things to
love about visual basic arrays started
at one unless you did something
somewhere in one place in the program
and then suddenly all the arrays
throughout the entire program started at
zero
and that was fun when somebody checked
that change in
but no visual basic for a raise decided
that
uh the square brackets might be a little
bit hard for visual basic programmers to
find on their keyboards they knew where
the round brackets were everyone knows
where the round brackets are so let's
just use the round brackets for arrays
and array indexing as well
so that's that's how visual basic does
things
so we say dim f round brackets 10 as
integer and then later on you see
something going f1 and you're kind of
like are you calling a function f and
passing one or are you getting the first
thing out of that f array also visual
basics
default integer type despite being a
32-bit language or a 32-bit compiler had
16-bit integers and so if you wanted a
32-bit integer you had to use long and
if you wanted a 64-bit integer you had
to write a com add-on in c plus plus
so we're doing that we like that we're
going to have round brackets for our um
for our array indexes and also our
integers are just going to be 17-bit
um because we've bought shares in all
the memory companies and so
we don't care about those other
um
15 bits that are that are being left
empty because that's just making people
buy more memory and that's making our
share value go up it's brilliant
c and c plus plus i did see programming
my first uh my first job
um it was on the job training it was
like an apprenticeship and i turned up
on my first day and they gave me a copy
of kernighan and ritchie's c programming
book and they said work through that at
that terminal there so i sat down at the
time i'm like how do i open a text
editor and he went oh type vi
and the name of the file and it'll just
create it for you sorry vi
hello dot c
and then trying to start typing and
there was a little semi-circle of all
the other programmers who'd been there a
bit longer standing around me going hey
he's just learned vi
so yes
but um c had this brilliant feature uh
called macros
which was essentially just string
substitution through the code and at the
time there was a big you know the holy
war so like vi versus emacs and net
versus java and um and all these
different things you know uh
react versus angular at the time it was
c versus pascal believe it or not pascal
was actually considered a viable
programming language back in 1989
and
that one of the arguments that the c
people had was that c was better because
you could declare a few macros at the
start of your c program and then it
would compile pascal code but there was
nothing you could do to pascal to make
it to compile c code and kind of like
that
i like what you've done
but it's not a good argument but i like
macros they they can make surprising
things happen so we're going to have
macros in bs
modern languages um like rust for
example
have what's called hygienic macros so
they're actual little processes that run
inside the compiler and can do
intelligent things and i like that idea
of being able to do something a bit more
intelligent than just basic string
substitution and actually there's
already a fantastic way to do more
complex string substitution so i'm just
going to use regular expressions
macros in bs are regular anything you
can express in a regular expression you
can turn into a macro in bs and the
specific regular expression syntax is
the one that you use in vi or vim for
search and replace so when you do column
percent s slash something slash
something else slash g
this is this is the same thing here so
this i've done define and then a capture
group and then thing and you've got the
carrot at the start and colon at the end
and then a dollar to say the end of the
string so this will match an entire
string and then it will replace that
with class and then whatever was
captured in that group so now in my code
when i write my greeter thing colon this
macro will come along and replace that
and turn that into class greeter
are you not entertained
so yes because because what could
possibly go wrong with that
so there are some things i'm not quite
sure on um
i'm still sort of thinking them through
static or dynamic typing so static type
i personally prefer a statically typed
language i'm a c-sharp developer um and
uh it's
other languages come along and i look at
them and go do i still want to be a yeah
no i'm fine um because c sharp is is
great and it's statically typed there
are times when that can be a bit
annoying and you sort of think i wish
this could be dynamic and then you
actually use the c sharp dynamic keyword
and you go no i don't um
but
uh so yeah there's there's a lot to be
said for static typing there's a lot to
be said for dynamic typing very quick
prototyping very easy to do test driven
development in a in a dynamically typed
language because you can you can
literally write the test first and it
will run uh in a statically typed
language if you write the test first and
you haven't written any of the
implementation it'll just go i'm not
compiling um so yes
so you know it's it's it's six of one
half a dozen of the other
and then i discovered that there's a
thing called gradual typing which
facebook um use in their their
programming language flow and actually
typescript originally did this it was
optional so you could put a type hint
python has this now as well as of like
3.8 i think python has type hints so you
don't have to but you can put a type
hint in there to say this variable
should be a string or it should be an
integer or it should be something um and
so yeah facebook and flow has this and
so we're going to do this gradual typing
thing in bs we're going to introduce a
new keyword is probably uh
and
because you know it's colon that could
mean anything at all so we're gonna have
is probably a we're gonna do localized
versions of this as well so so we'll do
a norwegian version with whatever the
norwegian for is probably uh is is going
to be in there as well also um grammar
is very important and in the english
language we have two indefinite articles
a and an and we use an when the word
after it starts with a vowel
or an h if you're very posh
um and so this is going to do grammar
checking as well and so you say is
probably a string but is probably an
integer
and if you get that wrong that'll be a
compiler error
but it'll just say invalid constant
script or compiled so
you know i quite like the idea of
scripted languages because it forces you
to send your source code out there and
then anybody who wants to can look at it
and see how terrible it is but compiled
is good too because if you compile the
code then it makes it much harder to
work out why it's running really really
slowly which is of course because we've
put for x equals zero to a million nop
in the machine code that has been output
or we can do semi-compiled so a lot of
languages are semi-compiled like c-sharp
and java for example is compiled to an
intermediate byte code and then you ship
that and then it gets jit compiled um
and so uh we're going to go for that
semi-compiled thing we're going to
generate this intermediate code but we
should also make sure that this compiles
to ecmascript 3 so that people can write
things that still run in internet
explorer 6
because it's still getting out there
um
how many times do you see it you're
watching on news particularly hospitals
this is the terrifying thing and
somebody's being interviewed and you
look behind them and you're going
that's windows xp
why have you got windows xp in your
hospital
why what are you doing
memory management um i like garbage
collected languages they make life nice
and easy you just create things and then
when you're finished with them there's
an automated process that comes along
and goes oh you're not using that
anymore i'll get rid of that for you
and clean up behind you um having worked
in c for five years where you had to
malloc
memory that you wanted and then put text
into it and then remember to free it
again later otherwise everything just
went to hell
and the really brilliant thing with with
c even back in like 19 1991 there was a
thing called lindt which could run over
your c code and it would point out to
you
when you had mallocked and you didn't
appear to have freed that anywhere and
you kind of like if you can do that in
the lint
why don't you just do it in the king
compiler
make my life easy rust has got this
whole thing going on with
only one thing at a time can own a
variable which it's it's a nightmare
there are two things so nothing is taken
from rust in this by the way because um
rust
is is very close to being the perfect
language um and rust's uh
borrow checker and and lifetime checkers
and all this sort of stuff they make
life very difficult
but the reason they're making life very
difficult is because the things you're
trying to do are really really bad and
you shouldn't be doing them and they
have the potential to cause your program
to crash and do unexpected things
and rust knows this and so rust isn't
going to let you do these things but
if you haven't tried rust just grab it
and and work through the first couple of
chapters of the rust book and do
something wrong because the error
messages in rust
it's like it's like a hug
from the compilers they're they're there
you did your best yes yeah no you see
you see here where you've done this no
you can't do that no
no it's bad no
what you probably want to do is this it
teaches you rust the compiler teeth is
lovely
so yeah we're not doing that definitely
our error messages are going to be hell
we're going to force our programmers to
free everything they're not going to
mallock them they're not going to know
that they've allocated them we're just
going to make them free them we're going
to use delete and delete is going to
start with a capital letter unlike every
other keyword because delete is
important you don't want to leak memory
and you have to delete everything if
you've used a variable you have to
delete it so there's no pass by
reference so the
the name parameter that's been passed
into our construct here that's a copy of
the name parameter wherever that came
from so now you own this this name
variable here so you have to delete that
when your function is finished any
parameters you took in any variables you
created the only thing you don't delete
is if your function returns something
then i actually know you have to delete
that as well because when it returns it
it'll make a copy of that and then the
thing that called the function will own
that and so after the return statement
you have to delete the variable you just
returned it's gonna be great what could
possibly go wrong everything that's the
point
loops
i'm a big big big big believer
in the the principle that if it's broke
you shouldn't fix it and if it isn't
broke you should fix it until it breaks
and then run away
hire me
but no there's there are four loops
there are while loops there are four
reach loops there are iterators there
are do while loops there's all different
ways of doing loops but we all know the
best way of doing loops thank you into
cal thank you basic is go to
so modern languages c has go to c sharp
has go to i actually use go to in c
sharp
um
not a lot
but
you know when you have a try method
in c sharp and it's got an out
and
you're going to do a bunch of things to
see if you can set that out variable and
then you're going to return true or
you're going to set that out variable to
its default value and return false
and
if there are like three or four
different ways that trying to do this
can fail you don't want to repeat that
set it to its default value and return
false so you put set it to its default
value and return false at the bottom of
your c sharp function and you put a fail
label on it so fail colon and then as
you're going through you just go go to
fail go to fail go to fail and then just
before you fail you set it to what it
should be in return through it
and there's nothing wrong with doing
that
and people go oh you've put goto in your
code people literally have like um
like net code analyzers that they've
written with roslyn just just to look
for the word go to just go ah you're bad
and you're kind of like a no i'm not
because it's in there and if it's in
there you should be allowed to use it
and b
write some code that doesn't use go to
and then go and look at the intermediate
language that is generated from that
what do you find in gotos all over the
place so i'm putting them in my code
but we're not going to have labels we're
going to have line numbers we're only
going to have line numbers though for
lines that you are going to
because what's the point of having line
numbers for anything else and because i
am a big fan of douglas adams line
numbers have to be a multiple of 42
uh so you have line 42 and then the next
line that you want to go to is going to
be line 84 and we're going to go up like
that and they have to be sequentially
increasing and by 42 each time
throughout your entire program and so if
you need to introduce a new one halfway
through you're going to have to manually
renumber all the go-to lines underneath
that
we'll sell a refactoring tool that will
do that for you twenty thousand dollars
so we're gonna say 42
echo thing
uh and and whatever else and then go to
42 unless
uh the decremented times is strictly
equal as your bang bang equals bang
operator to zero and so this will print
that string that number of times
um
the terrifying thing that i realized as
i was writing this example code
is
you could write a compiler that would do
that
that that that would potentially work
please don't
please i did this talk at build stuff in
2014
and
and
two different groups of people went off
and started github repos i was just kind
of no no no no there are much better or
worse things you could do with your time
so modern programming languages we've
got multi-core processors now we've got
um
my home machine has got
16 cores and each one of them is hyper
threading so it's 32 logical calls in my
machine so we have to support
parallelism we have to be able to
parallelize tasks so they can run as
fast as possible which means we need to
to do threads um and there's lots of
different ways that go has go routines
and there are says thread factory thread
uh was it
threadpool.q user work item and all
these sorts of things and i was trying
to think how can i
bring bring threading into bs
and i thought well
you know the basic people they like
having words for things like they're
like lots of keywords and stuff so let's
do something to to please the basic
people so if you want two pieces of code
to run at the same time in bs you just
say do this and this
and it will run both those lines of code
at the same time so it will run hello
and goodbye at the same time who knows
which one of those will finish first
it's indeterminate as threading should
be
so and that's that that makes sense to
me that's that's completely fine the
problem though with this way of doing
threads which i am now married to
um and i i cannot possibly contemplate
any other way of doing threads is is
it's not dynamic
so if i get an array of something and i
want to run an operation on each element
in that array
and i want to do that in a
multi-threaded way so like parallel.4 or
parallel.4 each in c sharp um there's
there's no way of doing that because
it's i it's got do and and and and and
and
so i i racked my brains and i thought
there must be a solution to this
and then i realized that there's a
terrible language from way back in the
mists of time that i hadn't taken
anything from yet which was fourth
fourth
was was a truly
weird language back in the 1950s i think
fourth came from
and fourth was the first language that
had the evaluate instruction
so in fourth you could write some code
in a string and then say to fourth
compile that and run it dynamically at
runtime
and actually so many languages um still
have you know you can do that in c sharp
with
uh with the rosalind compiler you can
generate an in-memory assembly and run
it at runtime and and there are
brilliant and clever things you can do
with that
javascript famously
json javascript object notation the
original idea with json was that it was
not just an object format it was also
valid javascript and so you could just
say eval a string and it would become an
in-memory object and people went that's
genius and other people went
so if i put a function in that string i
can do pretty much whatever i want on
your computer and the people who
invented jason when oh no there are bad
people in the world who knew
um
but no so we're going to bring in eval
for
for bs lang
and so if i want to do something
dynamically with threads then i can just
build up a string and so i'm going to
work through this
so we start
with
i as -1
oh
the gradual typing thing if the thing
you're passing in is an array then you
don't say like string bracket bracket
you say things are probably strings
or the equivalent
plural
conjugation of to be in the relevant
language so we say i to minus one and we
create an empty uh
that's a an ascii string
no it's an ansi string whatever it is um
and then we say line 42 we're going to
uh set threads to do
um uh
else we'll set threads to and will
append
um
and to threads unless i
is equal to
one
oh i forgot to mention earlier on
so yeah visual basics arrays started at
one most other programming languages
arrays start at zero
bs lang's arrays start at minus one and
then go down
because they can
and it is actually laid out backwards in
memory uh which will please all the java
people with their big endian integers
so yes so we start at minus one
this threads 42 threads is this else
threads is that
um and then unless so what we're saying
is unless i equals minus 1 do the line
above else
do the the line that starts with 42.
that's an inverted if statement using
unless there you go ruby that's how
stupid unless is
okay then we add the line to say the
things that we've currently got in our
string and then we go to 42
unless
negative and less decremented i
is less than the length of things the
length oh less than minus the length of
things so despite the fact that arrays
start at minus one and then go down when
you call len on an array it will return
a positive number
and actually that's fine because we are
all completely used to the fact that
when we get the length of an array in
any programming language except visual
basic to be fair um it will be one more
than the highest index
in that array so if you get up a bound
it'll be one less
so yes
then there is a a static method that is
in all no there is a method in all caps
on the string type in bslang called
evaluate which will just cause it to run
and then we have to delete threads and i
obviously because we're finished with
them
wouldn't you love to turn up to work
every day and just know that you were
going to work with this language
wouldn't that make you happy
no oh
suit yourself
um this is the the last item this is
something that dylan beatty actually
drew my attention to yesterday
in go
so in
every other language and go
does things differently
and i'm pretty sure it's just because
they're bastards
um they've just added generics in go
1.18
finally
after saying generics make things too
complicated for ages now write the same
function over and over and over again
for every possible type this array could
be
they've added generics but
for for generic type parameters and and
type arguments it's not angle brackets
it's square brackets
which they do also use for the array
indexer
apparently you can't use angle brackets
because they're also the less than and
greater than operator and so if you're
assigning two variables
uh if you say a comma b equals and then
you've got these things you have to the
passer would have to read ahead to work
out what was going on
so right make the passer read ahead to
work out what's going on what the [ __ ]
wrong with you it's not like the
passer's got better things to do than
read my code is it
but anyway they're doing that but goes
uh date handling whether you want to
format a date or pass a date so if we
want to format a date we can pass an
explicit string usually lowercase yyyy
uppercase m for the month and you've got
mm if you want to print it with two
digits and then mmm will do like jan feb
mar and mmm we'll just print the whole
thing
dd for day
hh for 12 hour clock capital hh for 24
hour clock lower case mm for minutes
lower case ss for seconds lowercase fff
for fractions
every programming language in the world
uses that now as far as i can tell it's
it's like this it's not an iso standard
not like the iso date format but it is
pretty much standard go doesn't
go
uses january the 22nd 2006
at three minutes past four and five
seconds
uh mountain time
so
seven hours behind gmt
that is goes magic date and so however
you want to format your date you write
that date in that format and then it
will turn whatever date you've actually
got into that same format
because
they're bastards that's the only thing i
can think of it's this is documented in
their code it has go doesn't use
yymmdd layout so they know it exists
they know about it but no they're not
going to use it instead you format a
special layout parameter monday january
the 2nd 150405
mst 2006 the same way as the time or
date should be formatted it has to be
that exact date and time
and then there's this line
this date is easier to remember when
written as 0102 345 pm060700
okay but
have you ever seen a date written like
that
i have never ever in my life seen
somebody format a date like that and
bloody americans they put the month
first
0-102 the 2nd of january no that's the
1st of february
so
it's too good it's going in um but i'm
going to use as my date uh the 21st of
november 2014 at 10 minutes past five
eastern european time uh which is the
start of the first time i ever gave this
talk um and
so i mean that's
okay it's it's not one two three four
five six seven like goes one's uh is but
you may find it easier to remember when
it's written as
twenty one oh five ten zero zero pm
uh apostrophe 14 plus zero two zero zero
um because there you go that's super
helpful
i learned a norwegian word
if you're not norwegian that means
you're welcome because i thought that
was more appropriate than thank you
so yes those those are my ideas for the
worst programming language ever
and and i do really want to thank go for
that last contribution that's that's
really tickled me um does anyone in the
audience we've got about uh seven
minutes left on the clock does anyone in
the audience have a a favorite feature
from their language that they think we
should adopt that they'd like to share
no
that's fine if you don't sometimes oh
yes hello
you despite well yes matlab and it
echoes out anything you don't and with a
semi-colon
it
matlab echoes out anything you don't end
with a semicolon any line it echoes out
whatever you did on that line
what i do is i go to the last slide as
i'm as i'm doing the presentation and i
add speaker notes for it
if i like it
i like it
where's my view thing
ah speaker note speaker note speaker
notes
outline view
no
notes page there we go
um
so matlab
echoes
out any line that
doesn't
end
with a semicolon or a greek question
mark obviously in in in bs
so yes that that's brilliant i love that
so yeah i'm gonna put that in for a
future one hello yes
i think maybe i'm
swearing in church but do you have
anything to say about
also or else
and also or
else
from vb
i'm not even familiar with those
okay
right so it would not evaluate further
things if
ah yes so if you did in in vb
6 if you did this and this and this and
this it would evaluate all of them even
if the first one was false
yes that's right and so they added
because you can't break existing
behavior because people could be relying
on side effects from the third thing in
the and sequence happening even when the
first one was false and so they
introduced and also
um to say the that which was the early
terminating and operator in if
statements
um
yeah i'd forgotten about that
yeah okay those are in there as well
um
so yes yes hello
yes
oh so if statements should require you
or sorry unless statements should
require you to break so
and functions i i like that
you're a twisted puppy
so
so here
um we would say 42 threads equal
something break
else threads equals break
um unless blah blah blah
go to 42 break unless
negative negative i and then after
delete threads and i we'd put break
yeah thank you
not going to be able to fit these on the
slides next time i do this talk
break
at
end of
every
scope
yep that's fantastic
anybody else have any suggestions yes
hello at the
can back function without braces
so like you call it function
yeah but it's just written as a variable
oh yes
i've seen
ruby does that as well doesn't it if
you're not passing parameters you don't
have to specify the parens
yeah i'll put that down there
optional
parens
when
function
has no
params yeah that that's awesome hello
yes
i think the language is a bit too
effective with less than
double minus
you would um
but
uh
so yeah and i thought about that the
sort of um pre-ink and posting course or
something like that um and doing it as a
function with like a ref parameter um
but then i thought if we put plus plus
and minus minus in there we might trick
programmers from c like languages to
going oh they're serious
that's good yes yes you do have that um
yep dash gt ah
there's a there is a left
i want to say it's vb but i don't think
it is
um
there was a programming language i think
it was one of the ones i evaluated at
the same time as vb and uh and gupta sql
windows because i looked at power
builder did anyone ever use power
builder
that sucked
informix new era
but i've seen a language which has
greater than and greater than equal and
less than and less than equal as
keywords and doesn't support just the
the mathematical operators for those
things
because apparently
according to unicode what we call the
less than and greater than characters
are not actually the less than and
greater than characters they're a type
of paren
the mathematical characters for less
than and greater than are hiding
somewhere else in the unicode character
set we've been sold a lie
so yeah
um right yes one more hello
you often have to prefix functions in
build functions right
yes
so
prefix everything with bs yes
oh so so some things will and some
things yeah okay
so
prefix
uh
let's say 69 because that all that
number makes my son laugh
he's 10.
um
thank you youtube
uh of um standard
library
uh members
with
bs
fantastic right our time is up thank you
all so much for coming um thank you for
for coming to the conference generally i
hope you had a great time
please safe journey home and uh take
care of yourself and i hope that we will
be back here in may june next year and
we can do this all again
cheers
[Applause]